[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
es gibt eine mauer mit und kam zwischen
freiheit und unfreiheit und sie wird
höher nicht jeder baum will
lieber herr bundeskanzler scholz reißen
sie diese mauer ein
guten abend zum heute-journal der
präsident der ukraine heute per video im
deutschen bundestag in seiner rede
erinnerte sie lenski auch an die
berliner luftbrücke
1948 49 als die sowjetunion die land und
wasserwege nach berlin blockiert hatte
eine solche luftbrücke las er sich für
die ukrainischen städte leider nicht
aufbauen vom himmel über der ukraine
fiel nur russische bomben und raketen
die lenski sparte nicht mit kritik daran
die deutschland in der vergangenheit
alle warnungen überhört hatte und die
geschäfte mit putin immer weiter
ausbaute und sie teils nach wie vor
weiterführen wie kann das sein fragte er
eine antwort gab es darauf nicht thomas
reichert berichtet
an diesem morgen müssen in berlin erst
mal alle warten russlands brutale
luftangriffe auf kiew sind plötzlich
sehr nah
ich will sie nur darüber informieren
dass die die veranstaltung mit herrn
selensky noch einen moment brauchen wird
die technischen verbindung sind gerade
nicht möglich weil es in kiew einen
anschlag gegeben hat um in unmittelbarer
nähe ein anschlag in unmittelbarer nähe
aber dann winke ukraine ist präsident
die abgeordneten applaudieren
erleichtert irgendwie seelands die aber
hätte es nicht ab von einer abrechnung
mit deutschland und dessen
russlandpolitik
warum ist das möglich wir haben unseren
euch gewendet und gesagt die nord stream
pipeline ist so was wie eine
vorbereitung auf den krieg als antwort
haben wir bekommen dass es da ein
wirtschaftlich wirtschaft wirtschaft
dann als selensky den abgeordneten in
deutschland von mario pohl dessen
bewohner rund um die uhr unter beschuss
seien für die russische armee seien alle
zielscheibe auch zivilisten
jedes jahr wiederholen politiker und
politikerinnen die worte nie wieder
jetzt sehen wir dass diese worte einfach
nichts wert sind in europa wird ein volk
vernichtet
die linz geredet von einer neuen mauer
die immer höher werde wenn europa nicht
helfe er spricht dem parlament ins
gewissen und scholz direkt an
lieber bundeskanzler scholz zerstören
sie diese mauer geben sie deutschland
die führungsrolle die deutschland
verdient hat
stoppen sie diesen krieg helfen sie uns
diesen krieg zu beenden
es lebe die ukraine
kanzler scholz könnte ja müsste jetzt
antworten er schweigt nach dem applaus
der eigenen ergriffenheit folgt der
nächste tagesordnungspunkt
vor eintritt in die tagesordnung
gratuliere ich dem kollegen
geburtstagsgrüße nur eine debatte zur
selen cigs hilferuf aber lehnt die ampel
ab union wie linke reagieren empört
meine damen und herren wann denn wenn
nicht jetzt eine diskussion eine
zwischenbilanz eine frage an uns selbst
sie müssen aufpassen dass sie nicht nach
100 tagen schon so arrogant sind wie
andere nach 16 jahren statt um hilfe für
die ukraine geht es am ende um die
geschäftsordnung und schuldzuweisungen
scholz sagt dann doch noch etwas zwei
stunden später im kanzleramt beim besuch
des nato-generalsekretärs verspricht der
der ukraine weitere finanzielle
humanitäre hilfe und militärgüter eines
aber gehört auch klar und deutlich
ausgesprochen die nato wird nicht
militärischen diesen krieg eingreifen es
wäre eine antwort an zielinski gewesen
im bundestag scheut aber hat erst mal
geschwiegen
und in berlin begrüßt sich den
nato-generalsekretär ians stoltenberg
gewinnen muss das totenbett
grillabend sie und bundeskanzler scholz
haben heute nochmal betont es werde
keinen direkten nato-einsatz geben ist
das eigentlich eine kluge strategie
wladimir putin immer zu versichern dass
er sich keine sorgen zu machen braucht
ich denke es ist wichtig hier klar zu
sein und wir sind klar sowohl war es
unsere verantwortung angeht die ukraine
zu unterstützen und die nato-verbündeten
und steigern ihre unterstützung für die
ukraine auch mit fortschrittlichen
waffen und das war sehr hilfreich wie
die in keinem weiter abwerten version
gleichzeitig halte ich es für wichtig
dass die nato ihre verantwortung gerecht
wird
also alles tun was sie unsere maschinen
eine eskalation des konflikts zu
verhindern über die grenze der ukraine
hinaus und deswegen sind wir ganz klar
nicht direkt beteiligen wir werden nicht
direkte nato truppen auf den boden
schicken oder auch die luft schicken und
wir steigern auch unsere präsenz auf der
präsenz auf der ausklang das bündnis um
unsere botschaft klar zu machen
deutlicher zu machen dass wir alles
machen werden um eine eskalation in
stara terium zu verhindern ja nochmal
meine frage wer hier eskaliert ist ja
nicht die nahtlosen mann ist putin und
kein mensch weiß wie weiter eskaliert
wäre sich an der zeit dass er ist mit
der angst zu tun bekommt die osteuropäer
sind ja offenbar bereits viel weiter zu
gehen allen voran polen
waren sind geeint in unserer antwort auf
diesen konflikt auf die invasion der
ukraine durch russland wir sind einig in
der unterstützung der ukraine muss
bedenken dass seit der illegalen
alexion der creme 21
14 die nato alliierten
zehntausende von soldaten
geschult haben die jetzt an der front
stehen und wir haben sie ausgerüstet die
ukrainische armee ist es wesentlich
stärker fiel besser aus als 20 14 und
unsere verbündeten
sind auch geeint unsere will terry jones
auf dem land in der luft und auf den
auf see zu verstärken damit es keine
möglichkeit einer falsch berechnung
eines missverständnisses gibt und das
geht auch darum dass wir die eskalation
des konflikts verhindern wollen
vladimir zealand ist ein bluetooth modul
unia seelands gehört heute an die
luftbrücke von berlin erinnert in seiner
stadt marjah obwohl passiert moment das
gleiche die stadt wird ja nicht nur
wobei die letzten belagert und
ausgehungert hält er fest dass aus diese
bilder die wir ja auch in echtzeit
bekommen nicht nur von toten kindern
sondern irgendwann auch von verhungerten
menschen auf den straßen wird hält der
westen das aus und bleibt dabei wir
betrachten das als regionalen konflikt
also ich verstehe natürlich die
verzweiflung von präsident jens geben
und des ukrainischen volkes und das ist
natürlich schmerzhaft uns nicht dort
sind einfach nur die bilder zu
betrachten und die berichte zu hören
über das leid über die zivilen und
deswegen unterstützen wir ja auch die
ukraine bauen unsere militärische
finanziellen unterstützung aus und
deswegen haben wir auch so viele
millionen von flüchtlingen jetzt
aufgehoben und wenn es oben eine
flugverbotszone geht dann müssen wir
wissen dass diese zone nicht einfach nur
deklariert werden kann dann muss sie
auch durch das ganze werk und eine
solche zone durchzusetzen
dazu muss man
massiv die russische luftverteidigung
waren barrieren
es gibt
märkte flugzeuge abschießen dann sollen
wir das machen dann gibt es eine
eskalation des krieges zu etwas was viel
mehr leid viel mehr zivile opfer fordern
wird und das der grund warum das nicht
machen es gibt aber den vorschlag einer
partiellen no fly zone im westen der
ukraine also direkt an der grenze zum
nato gebiet die zum beispiel auch mit
patriot raketen vom osten von polen oder
rumänien aus und geschützt werden könnte
dazu müssten keine nato flugzeuge direkt
in den luftraum eindringen ist das nicht
vielleicht eine idee
das müssen wissen dass auch eine
teilweise
flugverbotszone erfordern würden dass
wir russische flugzeuge angreifen würden
um diese flugverbotszone durchzusetzen
und um auch die flugabwehr die
luftabwehr auszuschalten darf der
russischen seite und eine solche
flugverbotszone also durchzusetzen wird
sehr wahrscheinlich zu einem vollen
konflikt zu einem krieg führen zwischen
der nato und russland und das wird
natürlich
unser westliches land
auslösen und das können wir uns nicht
vorstellen dass wird viel schlimmer
seiner so wie jetzt in der ukraine
erleben sie sprachen vorhin die an
ostflanke der nato an die jetzt
verstärkt werden soll das heißt die nato
russland grund akte von 1997 nach der
die nato nicht permanent große
truppenverbände in die neue nato
mitglieder stellt die ist eigentlich
erledigt die könnte man als eigentlich
auch formell putin kündigen oder
russland der grundtakt ist aus den 90er
jahren und was es dort steht drin steht
ist das
in der jetzigen sicherheitssituation ist
keine substanziellen kampftruppen an der
flanke geben wird aber seitdem hat sich
russland ja selbst aus dieser grund akte
verabschiedet und es gibt zum beispiel
auch darin steht auch drin dass man die
territoriale integrität aller länder
auch der ukraine waren würde und diese
integrität ist ja verletzt worden schon
20 14 und durch die die stabilisierung
des don bosco und danach und jetzt auch
durch die volle invasion in die ukraine
das heißt wir werden weiter
unterstützung leisten unsere
unterstützung ausbauen aber wir werden
unsere natürlich auch unsere präsenz
präsenz ausbauen arbeit die nato
russland grund aktiv wird und nicht
daran hindern das zu tun was notwendig
ist
alle verbündeten zu schützen als
deutenberg danken für das gespräch
vielen dank ihnen
das center wir mit dem nato
generalsekretär aus termingründen aber
späten nachmittag aufgezeichnet
der krieg in der ukraine und der
auftritt selensky ist im bundestag dazu
jetzt ein kommentar von chefredakteur
des zdf peter frey
auch standing ovations können eine
abfuhr sein so erging es heute dem
ukrainischen präsidenten selensky im
deutschen bundestag da schaltet sich ein
mann in lebensgefahr nach berlin und die
abgeordneten reagieren mit einer
geschäftsordnungsdebatte das ist
würdelos
ehrlich wäre gewesen das dilemma beim
namen zu nennen deutschland ist nicht
blind angesichts der verwüstung der
ukraine wir wollen keine neue mauer in
europa bauen wir liefern sogar waffen
aber wir wissen auch dass kampfflugzeuge
eine nato friedensmission oder gar eine
flugverbotszone für putin zum vorwand
würden seinen krieg auszudehnen und
dabei möglicherweise atomwaffen
einzusetzen
der bundestag hätte bekennen können dass
deutschland es sich viel zu lange zu
bequem mit putins gas und öl gemacht hat
selbst nach den angriffen auf georgien
und der besetzung der grimm haben wir
weiter weg geschaut jetzt sind keine
zweifel mehr möglich in der ukraine für
putin krieg gegen zivilisten der
präsident im kreml ist ein
kriegsverbrecher noch machen wir
geschäfte mit diesem russland wirtschaft
wirtschaft wirtschaft selensky legt den
finger in die wunde die epochale
kehrtwende die kanzler scholz der
pazifistisch angehauchten handels und
industrie macht deutschland verordnet
hat hilft dem mann dessen land gerade
zerstört wird nicht dem bundestag fehlte
heute der mut es selensky
direktzusagen deutschland muss auf zeit
setzen auf die zermürbenden folgen der
sanktionen in russland darauf dass
russland selbst den mann ab schüttelt
der zum alleinherrscher geworden ist
selbst kriegspartei zu werden einen
dritten weltkrieg zu riskieren dieser
preis ist nicht nur für deutschland zu
hoch
peter frei kommentierte dass dieser
krieg bewusst auch gegen die
zivilbevölkerung geführt wird zeigt sich
unter anderem daran dass seine stadt
belagert wird um sie im wörtlichen sinne
auszuhungern aus mario pohl gibt es
berichte nach denen die menschen in
ihrer verzweiflung wasser aus heizung
sru trinken
ähnlich ging die russische armee auch
schon in tschetschenien und syrien vor
syrer die das überlebt haben raten den
ukrainern dazu besser nicht zu markieren
wo sich krankenhäuser befinden oder wo
frauen und kinder schutz suchen das
würde nur die wahrscheinlichkeit erhöhen
dass genau diese gebäude bombardiert
werden kann seit jahren mit aktuellen
eindrücken vom kriegsgeschehen heute in
der ukraine
es ist wieder ein ziviles ziel das von
einer rakete getroffen wird ein
mehrstöckiges wohnhaus in der hauptstadt
kiew brennt wieder sterben zivilisten
dieser mann weint um seine mutter die
menschen unter schock
traumatisiert
russland hat uns angegriffen wir wissen
nicht wofür so ist der krieg
doch der russische vormarsch auf kiew
soll ins stocken geraten seien sagen
auch westliche geheimdienste die ukraine
während sich diese bilder sollen ein
angriff auf russische einheiten zeigen
durchhalteparolen vom bürgermeister
ich danke unseren amerikanischen
partnern und auch großbritannien für
moderne waffen zu unserer verteidigung
und die unterstützung in unserem kampf
für freiheit
gestern soll das russische militär das
theater der hafenstadt mario pohl
bombardiert haben obwohl
satellitenbilder zeigen dass vor dem
gebäude der russische schriftzug für
kinder steht
hunderte frauen und kinder sollen dort
vor angriffen zuflucht gesucht haben
hier aufnahmen vor dem angriff der
bürgermeister der stadt reagiert noch in
der nacht
wir wollen unsere augen schließen und
den alptraum vergessen der heute
geschehen ist das einzige wort das
beschreibt was heute geschehen ist ist
völkermord an den ukraine
am morgen dann die nachricht der
luftschutzkeller hat gehalten es soll
bisher nur verletzte geben russland
dementiert unterdessen einen gezielten
angriff auf das theater
natürlich ist das eine lüge russische
truppen bombardieren keine städte das
weiß doch jeder
experten sehen ein muster in der
russischen kriegsführung
kf zivilisten ganz groß ganz offen ganz
gezielt an das kalkül ist
mehrdimensional es geht darum den
widerstandsgeist zu brechen und vor
allem darum gebieten an friedrich zu
befreien dhc minister aus diesen
wohngebieten aus ihren
gebieten zu vertreiben um dann umso
rücksichtsloser diese gebiete zu setzen
und gegebenenfalls bombardieren zu
können mario pohl treffen russische
truppen auf massiven widerstand ein
panzer gerät hier unter beschuss die
stadt ist heftig umkämpft die menschen
eingekesselt 80 prozent des wohnraums
sind zerstört in den vergangenen tagen
sollen 30.000 menschen geflohen sein
denn auch die versorgung ist
abgeschnitten
wir haben nichts zu essen es ist
furchtbar nur noch furchtbar kein licht
keine heizung nicht grausam
einfach nur weg aus mario pohl das
wollen hier viele auch wenn das
lebensgefahr bedeutet
über drei millionen menschen sind
bereits aus der ukraine geflüchtet
innerhalb von nur drei wochen also mehr
als im ganzen jahr 2015 aus den
syrischen kriegsgebieten nach europa
kamen die meisten ukraine flüchtlinge
sind in polen aber auch nach deutschland
kommen täglich tausende viele
hilfsbereite hierzulande bieten private
unterkünfte an aber das reicht nicht es
braucht zentrale unterkünfte verteilung
koordination frank buchwald berichtet
dem krieg entronnen frauen und kinder
aus der ukraine
tausende kommen hier an jeden tag heute
war der bundespräsident bei ihnen am
berliner hauptbahnhof mein eindruck ist
sehr dass die deutschen wissen dass wir
uns hier dauerhaft verantwortlich fühlen
müssen ein paar hundert meter südlich im
kanzleramt
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz thema
flüchtlinge die länder rufen um hilfe
berlin ist im moment in einer situation
wo man ein bisschen
ja in die zukunft schauen können wie es
bald in einen bundesländern sein wird
die menschen schnell mit dem nötigsten
versorgen sie registrieren dabei sagt
der bund den ländern hilfe zu
wir wollen all diesen frauen männern
kindern jungen und älteren schnell und
möglichst unkompliziert zuflucht und
unterstützung gewährt
bund und länder werden dazu alle ihren
zur verfügung stehenden kräfte bündeln
um den geflüchteten die notwendige hilfe
zu bieten um einzelheiten soll sich nun
eine arbeitsgruppe kümmern erst mal
komme es darauf an für familien auf der
flucht eine neue bleibe zu finden
wir müssen dafür sorgen dass diese
frauen und kinder möglichst kurs im
großen aufnahme einrichtungen sind in
hallenberg von messen oder turnhallen
möglichst schnell in ordentliche
wohnungen kommen wo sie dann auch
bleiben können ministerpräsident wüst
zugeschaltet aus jerusalem er steht
unter quarantäne regen corona ein thema
das die bund länder runde seit zwei
jahren beschäftigt auch heute wieder
ja es wurde in der runde nämlich auch
über den umgang künftig mit corona
debattiert also über das für den 19 märz
geplante ende der meisten ein
dämmungsmaßnahmen konter lancieren
berlin das heißt da sollten darunter
heute schon heftigen streit gegeben
haben
ja das ist wahrscheinlich eine frage des
standpunktes den olaf scholz hat in der
darauffolgenden pressekonferenz das
ganze eine sehr konstruktive diskussion
genannt wer heute allerdings
informationen direkt aus
teilnehmerkreisen bekommen hat unter
anderem auf wir hatte dann doch den
eindruck dass die bundesländer damals
ihrem geballten ärger luft gemacht haben
parteiübergreifend haben die
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten im prinzip
geschimpft darüber dass sie sich nicht
mitgenommen fühlen dass der bund die
zusammenarbeit aufgekündigt habe dass es
der falsche zeitpunkt sei für die
änderungen die jetzt im
infektionsschutzgesetz
anstünden und hendrik wüst hat das ganze
zusammen gefasst hat gesagt die
maßnahmen die da jetzt
vorgesehen sein design zu langsam für
den notfall die hürden seien zu hoch und
das ganze sei rechtlich nicht umsetzbar
man muss allerdings dazu sagen viel
ändern wird dieser wutausbruch nicht die
ampel kann die änderungen im bundestag
mit der eigenen mehrheit durchsetzen und
im bundesrat werden die länder das nicht
blockieren aber was sollten daraus dann
jetzt in der praxis also prinzip macht
ab nächster woche jedes bundesland mehr
oder weniger seine eigene pandemie-
politik ja und im grunde ist auch genau
das ihr angedacht gewesen die ampel
macht diese änderungen ja dann
grundrechts einschränkungen nur noch
dort vorgenommen werden wo corona
maßnahmen dringend notwendig sind um zum
beispiel eine überlastung von
krankenhäusern oder das des
gesundheitssystems zu verhindern die
frage ist jetzt allerdings nur wie lässt
sich das umsetzen die bundesländer sagen
wir müssen das in die praxis umsetzen
und die vorgaben in dem neuen gesetz
sind so unklar dass wir überhaupt nicht
wissen wie das im einzelnen aussehen
wird das muss jetzt jedes land für sich
prüfen das spricht nicht für besondere
einheitlichkeit am ende die
einheitlichkeit scheint heute vor allem
in der verunsicherung zu bestehen und
vielleicht ist das auch ein grund warum
olaf scholz in der runde noch zu sagen
musste dass die dass der bundestag sich
sofort wieder an änderungen des gesetzes
setzen wird wenn sich die lage noch
einmal dramatisch verschärfen sollte
weil corolla danke schön herr unterlag
für diese einschätzungen aus berlin und
dann ist da ja auch noch das umstrittene
thema impfpflicht damit geht es jetzt in
den nachrichten bei gehalts der
bundestag hatte das thema heute auf der
tagesordnung die abgeordneten
debattierten erstmals über mehrere
gesetzentwürfe und anträge die zum teil
fraktionsübergreifend sind das spektrum
der vorschläge reicht von einer
impfpflicht für alle erwachsenen bis zum
antrag gegen eine gesetzliche
verpflichtung nach weiteren beratungen
soll dann im april eine entscheidung
fallen jetzt zur corona lage und der
blick auf die zahlen das robert koch
institut meldet
1931 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
32.000 179 mehr als vor einer woche
278 todesfälle kamen hinzu auch die
sieben tage instituts steigt über den
höchstwert vom vortag auf etwa
1.600 51
vom bundesgerichtshof kommt ein urteil
zu wirtschaftlichen folgen von
staatlichen corona maßnahmen demnach
haben gastronomen und andere
betriebsinhaber die im kronauer lockdown
im frühjahr 2020 schließen mussten
keinen anspruch auf staatliche
entschädigung für ihre einnahmeausfälle
hilfsleistungen seien hier keine aufgabe
der staatshaftung und mit
unterstützungsprogrammen wie corona
hilfen sei man der sozialstaatlichen
verpflichtung nachgekommen
schauen wir auf die wirtschaft insgesamt
mehrere forschungsinstitute haben ihre
wachstumsprognosen für dieses jahr
gesenkt frank bethmann wie sehen sie die
lage im moment ja sämtliche einschätzung
der institute sind im grunde genommen
makulatur nichts gilt mehr was im
wesentlichen dem ukraine schock
geschuldet ist sagt beispielsweise das
institut für weltwirtschaft die killer
halbierten heute ihre
wachstumsvorhersagen für dieses jahr
ähnliches gab im verlauf des tages der
konjunkturchef des in essen ansässigen
rwe instituts thorsten schmidt zu
protokoll der krieg in der ukraine
belastet die erholung der deutschen
wirtschaft von der korona krise stark
den schaden für die deutsche
volkswirtschaft taxieren die kieler
forscher bereits jetzt auf 90 milliarden
euro für die kommenden beiden jahre eben
weil viele betriebe teile nicht mehr
bekommen absatzmärkte verlieren oder
einfach eine verdopplung oder gar
verdreifachung der energiekosten nicht
mehr verkraften können stellvertretend
dafür die deutsche chemieindustrie kaum
eine branche benötigt für die
herstellung ihrer produkte mehr energie
entsprechend groß die sorgen 70 prozent
der unternehmen haben große probleme mit
den hohen energiepreisen 85 prozent
können laut einer aktuellen
mitgliederumfrage die steigenden kosten
nicht oder nur teilweise an ihre kunden
weitergeben hier stünden unternehmen vor
der zahlungsunfähigkeit warnt der
chemieverband vc ii heute bei der
vorstellung der zahlen nach den auto-
und maschinenbauern stellen chemie und
pharma den drittgrößten industriezweig
in deutschland damit über 460.000
beschäftigten insgesamt also heute große
verunsicherung und bittmann vielen dank
der ehemalige vorsitzende der
linkspartei oskar lafontaine ist aus der
partei ausgetreten
er wolle nicht länger einer partei
angehören die die interessen der
arbeitnehmer und rentner nicht mehr in
den mittelpunkt stellen erklärte der
78-jährige
lafontaine hatte gestern mit einer rede
im saarländischen landtag seine
politische karriere beendet mit seinem
austritt zehn tage vor der landtagswahl
ist das gegen ihn laufende
parteiausschlussverfahren vom tisch
lafontaine war von 2007 bis 2010
parteichef der linken davor war
lafontaine zwischen 1995 und 1999 spd
vorsitzender und unter kanzler schröder
finanzminister
bei dem schweren erdbeben im nordosten
japans sind mindestens vier menschen ums
leben gekommen mehr als 100 wurden
verletzt das beben in der region
fukushima hatte eine stärke von 7,4
zahlreiche straßen und gebäude wurden
beschädigt millionen menschen waren
zeitweise ohne strom in der ruine des
havarierten atomkraftwerkes von
fukushima gab die atomaufsichtsbehörde
entwarnung eine ausgelöste tsunami
warnung wurde mittlerweile aufgehoben
das was im heute-journal gleich im
anschluss geht es mit der sendung
maybrit illner weiter in der runde
sitzen heute unter anderem der
botschafter der ukraine andrej
melnitschenko
und um 0.30 meldet sich dann hanna
zimmermann mit unserem heutigen update
auf wiedersehen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend heute trennte noch die
kleine kaltfront von tief gesine das
hoch oliver von dem hoch peter das wird
sich aber am wochenende ländern gut zu
erkennen ist auch diese schafe wolken
grenze und dass diese wolken so extrem
weiß erscheinen liegt auch an ihrer höhe
ausgelöst durch den saharastaub gab es
da einfach sehr viele wolken die beiden
hochs allerdings die werden jetzt am
wochenende mehr und mehr verschmelzen
und am sonntag liegt dann dieses hoch
nordöstlich von uns das bedeutet viel
sonnenschein allerdings auch einen
kräftigen wind aus östlichen richtungen
heute nacht ist es erstmal noch stärker
bewölkt hier zwischen der uckermark und
dem alpenrand und im südwesten kann es
leicht regnen
im nordwesten ist es dagegen klar da
bildet sich nebel und es kann durchaus
auch mal glatt sein werden die
temperaturen sinken auf 0 bis -4 grad
milder bleibt die nach dem osten und dem
süden bei 8 bis 4 grad die
höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen bei 8
grad in den östlichen mittelgebirgen und
bis zu 16 grad am rhein denn im westen
aber auch in schleswig-holstein scheint
morgen schon wieder häufig die sonne vom
blauen himmel dichte sind die wolken
noch im osten auch mit dem saharastaub
da zeigt sich die sonne häufig nur so
verschleiert am samstag wird es dann
vielleicht für etwas schnee oder
schneeregen im erzgebirge reichen danach
wird es von tag zu tag sonniger und
milder und wie sie hier am trend für
freiburg im breisgau sehen können bleibt
es die gesamte nächste woche wohl
trocken guten abend